cómo evalúa lo que es el enfoque en
materia de seguridad en el que se basa
este plan de combate contra la violencia
que lanzó Ecuador
Santiago un saludo cordial es es
preocupante la situación que vive el
Ecuador tiene es bastante preocupante
porque la violencia escalado a niveles
inimaginables tenemos o contamos
diariamente con asesinatos con robos con
extorsiones a negocios y esto de aquí a
empujado al gobierno nacional a tomar
dos medidas Yo diría que drásticas una
de ellas desde el decreto de estado de
excepción en dos provincias y en tres
ciudades que incluyen el toque de queda
Es decir de que las personas no puedan
salir de sus casas de una de la mañana a
cinco de la mañana y también una medida
que resulta bastante compleja que es el
porte de armas para para civiles con
fines de defensa personal no un porte
que el gobierno dice que es regulado
pero que resulta alarmante digamos
también en un en un país en el que las
cifras de feminicidio son muy altas no
precisamente hacia este tema en concreto
quisiera apuntar ahora
Qué consecuencias Podría tener armar a
toda una población no podría empeorar la
situación aumentar más los índices de
violencia Incluso como usted decía de
violencia de género de feminicidios
este este es uno de los riesgos que
existe precisamente porque es una medida
que técnicamente no ha sido analizada en
función de establecer si la sociedad se
encuentra preparada para para tener esta
digamos esta situación que es un porte
libre de de armas regulado evidentemente
con con permisos Existen algunas
restricciones para quien porte armas
también pero que de todas maneras
involucra armar a toda la población
civil sumamente preocupante porque el el
país tiene índices de violencia muy
altos no solamente de género sino
también índices de violencia de manera
general que pondrían en riesgo yo creo
que principalmente las mujeres y a los
niños
Ximena por último Quisiera regresar a
este enfoque no de las medidas cree que
quizás se deja de lado lo que es atacar
las causas y no tanto las consecuencias
de la problemática
Sí de hecho el este decreto de estado de
excepción todavía tiene que entrar
análisis de la corte constitucional en
Ecuador y hay algo que la corte
constitucional ha insistido desde hace
mucho tiempo ya Y es que la violencia
los índices de violencia en el Ecuador
no pueden solucionarse con Estados de
excepción que tienen que haber ya
soluciones más más contundentes que
ataquen más las causas reales de la
violencia para que el estado pueda
solucionar y no generar paliativos que
que pueden de todas maneras ser
riesgosos también